welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for a presentation titled
detection and monitoring
of mutations from liquid biopsies a
clinical study
it's my pleasure to introduce you to
monica sado
the senior development scientist from
the genomics and cellular research
at sativa for complete biography of our
speaker please visit the tab at the top
of your screen
now if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them through the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions
following the end of the presentation
please join me now in welcoming monica
sedol
i will now turn the presentation over to
her
welcome monica
good morning and good afternoon everyone
thank you for the introduction
my name is monica seidel and i'm part of
rnd team
at sativa in genomic and diagnostic
solution business segment
our mission at sativa is to accelerate
and advance therapeutics
and by doing so we believe that we are
getting closer to the situation where
access to
a life changing therapy is widely
available
and how do we achieve our mission we
achieve our mission by providing
the customers with tools and services
for diagnostic related research and we
also maintain
a wide network of collaboration
including academic institutions
where this kind of research is taking
place today i will be talking about
liquid
biopsies and their application in cancer
diagnostic
this is a rapidly growing field uh
fueled by
uh current focus and development and
advances
in precision medicine
so what would be covered in my
presentation
as an introduction i will briefly cover
liquid biopsies
and then i will describe different type
of nucleic acids that can be found
in in the bloodstream and they have
obviously different relevance and
applicability
into biomarker profiling and then we'll
dive a bit deeper into our cell free dna
nucleic acid and the only type of
analyte that is currently used in
clinical practice
we will consider challenges associated
with liquid biopsies and we also
will discuss some avenues that are being
undertaken in order to
overcome those challenges the kolma
presentation
will focus on results of a study that we
conducted
in which we tried to answer the question
whether a site selection
assisted extraction of cell free dna
can allow for higher sensitivity of
cancer-associated mutation
detection
the term liquid biopsy covers the
collection
of bodily fluids for the purpose of
genetic profiling
and there's a number of different bodily
fluids can that can be collected for the
purpose
uh including urine cerebrospinal fluid
uh saliva
but this is the blood that is being
currently used and
in clinical practice and is mostly
investigated
the first report describing the presence
of nucleic acids
in the bloodstream goes back to 1948
however at this particular point in time
the discovery was completely unnoticed
and put to rest for
roughly another 15 years when another
report
showed that fetal dna can be found and
detected in maternal plasma
this discovery laid the foundation for a
non-invasive prenatal screening that is
currently being used
in a clinical practice for detection of
chromosomal unemployed in pregnancies
and this amazing success that the liquid
biopsies achieved in this field
triggered
extensive research and to the
possibility of using
liquid biopsies for biomarker profiling
and cancer cardiovascular disorders
autoimmune diseases diabetes or
for early detection of organ rejection
and transplant allergy
excuse me as for cancer
related use for liquid biopsies their
applicability
is being researched in both early and
advanced
stage cancer and for early stage cancer
it's mostly
evaluated in terms of being a screening
tool so
we are trying to find find out whether
liquid biopsies
are able to detect cancer and otherwise
healthy individuals so in those patients
that
do not present any clinical
manifestation of the disease but cancer
is already developing
and although there is a one fda approved
test for a screening of early cancer and
this is a very challenging
uh field and this is mostly due to the
limited sensitivity of detection cancer
of detecting cancer associated mutations
because in an early stage cancer the
amount of
tumor the right fraction of the
circulation is extremely low the
reported sensitivity varies depending on
the cancer type
and cancer location between 30 and 80
percent meaning that the risk of false
negative results
is extremely high similar challenges
apply to the use of liquid biopsies in
the detection of minimal residual
disease
so this would correspond to the
detection of cancers
the much higher success rate for liquid
biopsies is found in advanced cancer and
this is reflected in the current
guidelines advocating the use of liquid
biopsies
for genetic profiling and circumstances
where tissue biopsy is not available and
this applies to advanced cancers such as
lung cancer
prostate cancer or breast cancer
and another field which holds a lot of
promise for liquid biopsies is for
monitoring purposes
and this will be monitoring how well the
therapy is working
and also monitoring and the actuations
and unfortunately happen
in majority of patients following the
first line of therapy
and what needs to be said is the biggest
advantage of liquid
biopsy is its potential to uncover the
whole
genetic landscape of the tumor all
happened in the tumor in a spatial and
temporal
manner and for that reason um
[Music]
there's a number of different cell free
nucleic acid that can be found in this
circulation
if we concentrate on rna there are two
main groups
one is non-coding rna and the second is
coding rna so coding a renamer is
represented by
a messenger rna which encodes protein
and this is a minor fraction in the
circulation
and in in its intact form is almost
exclusively found in exosomes uh the
reason behind it is
when mrna is released into the
bloodstream
it's rapidly degraded by nucleases and
for that reason
um constitutes a rather unsuitable
analyte for biomarker profiling
among non-coding rnas which is a very
diverse set of
of molecules but majority of them with a
few exceptions are responsible for
gene expression modulation it is the
micro
rna which attracted the highest amount
of attention
those are small molecules of around 18
to 24 base per
base burst uh long and
they are quite stable in the circulation
due to the to the fact that they are
being
uh in complexes with protein and they
are responsible
for translational silencing of genes and
this is
done through a microarrangement binding
to
a three prime untranslated region in
their messenger rnase
so one microrna can target the number of
messenger rnase and this is because this
interaction happens for non
non-full complementarity of two strands
and this is a heavily researched area
number of reports show
a specific cancer related
signature profile of micro rna
expression
now if we go into dna we can divide the
dna
found into the circulation based on its
origin so it's either mitochondrial dna
or selfie dna that is represented by
genomic dna released by a number of
cells cells
in the organism and 100 dna research is
in
in an infancy and it's not
currently used in any of the of the
analytical methods for biomarker
profiling
although there are a number of reports
uh showing uh that it's exclusively
released by
tumor cells and might be used for cancer
detection
on the contrary cell free dna is already
in clinical practice
is used for a non-invasive prenatal
screening is used in circumstances with
tissue biopsy
is not feasible in advanced cancer
and is also used in passive screening
for colorectal cancer in patients which
i'm able to
undergo colonoscopy
diving deeper into selfrid dna
characteristics uh
first of all it is uh released into the
bloodstream through
active and passive mechanisms and those
active mechanisms are not fully
understood
as for passive release is mostly done by
the way of necrosis and hypothesis
uh sulfur dna represents the pull of
genomic dna released by a number of
different cells including
inflamed cells tumor cells fetal cells
in pregnancy but it is believed that the
majority
of social dna and the bloodstream is of
hematopoietic
origin and in terms of the
size of cell free dna the peak is
centered around 170 baseballs this is
corresponding to the size of the
nucleosome
uh and this size profile of itself dna
you can see on the right hand side of
the slide this is a electrophorogram
created with the use of bioanalyzer and
you showed that the size of sulfate dna
ranges between 100 to 300 base pair but
indeed the peak is around 170 pacers
there is number of reports um
showing that sulfur dna is fragmented
in a different way depending on its
origin
and what is also important and initially
this
was something that was considered to use
in cancer
screening and detection is that the
amount of cell free dna
is highly um is highly increased in
advanced cancer however it turned out
that
this high amount of cell creatine is
also
associated with other conditions such as
pregnancy
autoimmune disorders or following
strenuous exercise
so if you have a look at this slide
which is a very busy slide and i have no
intention to go for all the
uh publications that are being listed in
the table
i just wanted to attract the attention
of the audience to the fact
that selfie dna which is derived from
tumor
is highly fragmented and all those
publications i left in the table
uh give three conclusions uh first of
all the fact that the amount of
cell-free dna in advanced cancer
is much higher than healthy individuals
secondly and that there is a clear shift
in the size
of cell free dna in cancer patients
there were
lower fragments somewhere around or
somewhere below 150 base
and thirdly that those fragments uh
they are smaller than virgin tumor
fraction
so the biggest challenge of
cell free dna and its utility
permutation detection is sensitivity
this sensitivity uh limited sensitivity
originates of course from the
end point detection i say that they are
being currently used for biomarker
profiling
but it's also inherent to the specific
characteristic that
selfie dna possesses uh so first of all
the amount of selfie dna in that stream
it's
uh particularly low but what is even
lower
is the fraction that derived from the
tumor
an early stage cancer dysfunction is
within point zero one percent and goes
up to thirty percent
in um apostatic uh advanced uh cancer
on the top of this if we want to use
liquid biopsies to monitor
uh tumor evolution you can imagine that
those
clonal cells within the tumor then
constitute even lower fraction
of the tumor itself and what doesn't
help the situation is quite
often that during plasma processing and
there is
a significant release of genomic dna
from white
cells that further dilutes tumor device
fraction
and what i mentioned earlier is also the
fact that self-free dna that
comes from cancer cells is highly
fragmented and also is damaged
meaning that sometimes er is present in
a single stranded form
or in double stranded form where one of
the strands is nicked
this imposes a lot of challenges because
uh
almost majority of the majority of
currently use
next generation library preparation
methods use uh double-stranded library
preps
which unfortunately are not allowing to
capture
those small fragments and those next
fragments
and the endpoints in the endpoint
library
and an ngs analysis
and if we now go to the different
technologies they're being used for uh
detection of mutations
i listed both two different ones uh one
is digital droplet pcr
and the second one is targeted ngs you
can see that both of those methods they
have a
different limit of detection
and this limit of detection varies
depending on
some uh technological changes that are
being implemented
to the to the standard uh technique in
order to lower limit of detection for
ngs for example that would be use of
unique molecular identifiers that would
allow to eliminate
pcr-created errors or
the use of bioinformatic tools that
allow to eliminate sequencing errors
and nevertheless the first question that
everyone will probably ask
if the limit of detection for digital
drug with pcr is so low
why isn't it this technique exclusively
used for biomarker profiling
and the reason behind this is that
although it has extremely low
sensitivity this method requires
uh requires that the user knows the
mutation up prior to the detection
so you need to know what we are looking
for when you are using when you are
using digital pcr
in terms of targeted ngs this upper
knowledge of mutation identity is not
needed
what is needed is the identity of the
gene that we want to investigate
and there are not a number of different
panels
um that allow sequencing genes that are
well known to be associated with cancer
um so on the previous slide i discussed
the challenges
uh associated with typical
characteristics uh
that uh cell free dna has
and there are a number of unused avenues
that can be undertaken
uh to mitigate those problems so for
example
uh for the release of genomic dna and
the increased
yield in cell for dna extraction uh
it has been now advised uh to use
specific type of blood collection tubes
that allow to limit genomic dna release
from white blood cells and increase
the stability of cell free dna again for
library preparation
it has been suggested that in some cases
single stranded library preparations
might be more suitable in order to
capture those
necked and single stranded fragments of
of dna
and then i already mentioned the use of
bioinformatics tools to eliminate
sequencing error and ngs
and also use of unique molecular and
identifiers
to eliminate pcr amplification errors
and there is also another another point
at at which we can try to uh to mitigate
the problems related to selfie dna and
this is the extraction
um so here at sativa we develop uh
sorry extract of cell free dna kit and
that
is based on magnetic beat technology and
has uh three features that we believe
and allow to to increase the sensitivity
in endpoint essay and those three
critical points
is the fact that the kit allows to
allow allows to capture a low fragments
in a very efficient way
the kit allows to extract cell free dna
to the high extent
and the third aspect of the kit is
the fact that uh it allows for
elimination of genomic dna carryover
this principle is illustrated on the
electro ferrogram that you can see on
the right hand side of the slide
so if we have a look uh the blue trace
represents
uh plasma extracted with our kit uh but
before extraction the plasma will spike
with dna ladder
and this dna ladder is represented in
the green
and the green trace so when you have a
look
at the efficiency of extraction of small
fragments you can see that the blue line
overlaps very well with the green line
in lower molecular weight
range for example for 50 and 100 base
pairs
and when you have a look at the higher
molecular weight
recovery you can see that about 300 base
pairs the recovery
declines rapidly and at 2
kb this recovery is around 20 or below
20
meaning that the um carrier of genomic
dna
is minimized
so we of course wanted to see how our
kid performs
against leading brands uh so we
benchmark
the kid against uh mark max selfrey dna
kid which is manufactured by thermofish
scientific
and we also tested the kid against a
cayenne
mini lotket which is manufactured by
cryogen
um so in terms of kyogen kit this is a
silica base kit that is not very easy to
be automated
it can only be automated on instruments
manufactured by kyogen
in terms of magma kits this is a very
similar formula to citrificate is based
on magnetic bead technology
which allows for automation so if we
concentrate on the sulfur dna yield that
can be
seen on this graph you can see that
there is not much difference in the
extract and efficiency between
three different kits they are pretty
much similar
uh however uh when you have to do
genomic dna carry over
uh we have an obvious advantage in the
field it is certificate that allows
to significantly reduce the presence of
regenerative dna
uh in the uh in the and the extract
um obtained
from patient serum
of course we are very encouraged from
those results but
the main question that we ask is whether
those key
performance characteristics that i just
described for our kid
allow to achieve higher sensitivity of
mutation detection
in clinically relevant scenario and for
that reason
and so to answer the question uh we had
designed
a small study that involved four
patients
and they were all diagnosed with an
advanced stage
lung cancer they donated blood this
blood was
a process and plasma was extracted
the plasma was subjected to library
preparation
and tumor profiling was done using
targeted ngs
so a bit more about patient
stratification and why we decided to go
with patients
with non-small cell lung cancer so first
of all
this is the concept that unfortunately
is usually detected in a very advanced
stage
and the reason behind this because first
of all there are no screening
tests for this cancer and secondly
the cancer usually is asymptomatic and
starts giving symptoms symptoms with
metastasis
already occurred
the genetic profiling is
currently using clinical practice in
order to
discover mutations that can be targeted
to a specific type of therapy
and this genetic profiling is a device
uh
for testing the mutation and the
mutations in five genes which are listed
in
this table and this includes egfr alk
ross one uh brass and ntrk
all those uh genes they called for
protein kinases
and all all of those protein cases
kindness they have specific inhibitors
can can be used to treat
uh to treat patients and what is also
important and
this is the other reason why we decided
to go for uh
for those uh for those cohort of
patients is the fact that
uh in advanced lung cancer in
circumstances with tissue biopsy is not
available
liquid biopsy uh is advocated uh by
uh currently uh current by current
clinical
guidelines and the next and very
important
aspect of this cancer is unfortunate
resistance that occurs in the majority
of patients following first-line target
therapy
and this is specifically true from
patients that
are positive for mutation in egfr
and usually within 12 months
all of those patients develop secondary
resistance and the second
resistance is either related to
additional mutation in the egfr gene
itself
or after some bypass mechanism that for
example
involves amplification and mats in matte
gene
okay so
the plasma that was obtained from those
patients was extracted
using three kits and we used the same
kids as i discussed on
previous slides so this was the magma
skit from climate visual scientific
and a kyogen kit kiwam
which is based on silica columns and
all patients but one uh were processed
with all three kids
only patient one was processed with
sativa and kyogen kit
and this is this was due to the
limitation
in sample volume um
[Music]
the extract were analyzed using
capillary
capillary electrophoresis on by analyzer
and maybe
we first concentrate on the right hand
side of the slide
and we see three electro ferrograms and
the green trace
uh represents uh sativa extract the blue
trace represent mac max extract and the
orange one is
from hyagen as you can see here the
amount of cell free dna so the main
peak centered at around 170 base per is
similar between three different kits
however if you have a look at a genomic
dna
peak that would represent anything above
700 base spray
you can see that this is uh present in
um both kaioshin and macmax extracts
however
as far as i t because it's almost
completely accent
when we go to the left-hand side of the
slide and this is the summary of the
results
so the top uh graph represents
the cell phone dna yields separated by
the patient and by the kids
and even though there's a lot of
diversity in the extraction profile
you can see that pretty much overall the
performance of all three kits
is similar and the clear difference
is when we go to genomic dna
contamination this is summarized in the
lower graph
you can see that this is the scientific
kit that allows
to limit and genomic dna presence in the
extract
okay um so all of those extracts
were subjected to a library preparation
and this um library preparation um
that we performed i used the total
volume of all samples
and the targeted sequencing was done
using island tolerant technology and the
targeted
panel that we use is the panel that was
developed by biosept and it's called
biocell target selector ngs lung panel
it allows to sequence 12 genes
that are well known to be related to
lung cancer
what needs to be said at this point is
that
library preparation sequencing and data
analysis
was performed at biosearch
and so what you see on the slide those
are
results from targeted ngs
and i'm going to discuss those results
in different subsequent slides but maybe
we can just concentrate and compare the
mutational
frequency between patients and between
between
that were used for extraction
as you can see in all cases from patient
four to patient one
it is a sativa kit that allows uh to
detect mutation
at the higher frequency and this
obviously indicates and that
when plasma is processed with our kit
the extract is an
origin tumor derived and the right
fraction what you can see in the lower
uh table this is the analytical
sensitivity
of the target selector and you can see
that for uh
hotspot uh single nucleotide variants uh
deletions and insertions
and the limit of detection goes to point
one percent
uh for the novel mutations this limit of
detection is at five
excuse me it's 0.5
okay let's now try to dive a bit deeper
into
uh into each of the patients so let's
concentrate on patient two and four
both of those patients uh were found
positive
uh for uh mutation and b raf kinase
and this is the mutation at the position
600 which
uh which results in the replacement of
valine with aspartic acid
and this mutation is a phosphomatic
mutation means that even though the
protein is not phosphorylated
uh the presence of negatively and
negatively charged aspartic acids make
the protein active
and through this activity uh the kinase
activates downstream effectors so
activates mark kinase
and this signaling leads to the
uncontrolled growth and proliferation of
the cells
and this is a very well known mutation
for melanoma and not
that prevalent in non-small cell lyme
cancer
i think it's only visible it's only
present two percent of the patients so
so quite rare
and nevertheless which is quite
beneficial for the patients there is
a targeted therapy and this targeted
therapy is
both approved in the european union and
and in the united states
and involves the use of two drugs
targeting
two different kinases uh so the
the first drug uh targets beer kinase
the second drug
uh targets a map kinase and what you can
see on the on the table on the right
this is the table taken from
novartis website with a manufacturer of
both of both drugs
you can see the clear benefit for those
patients
where you can see that overall survival
has increased to 20
to 24 months
what i wanted to concentrate on those
slides i wanted to
analyze again and go and slightly deeper
into the
genomic dna carry over the yield of cell
free dna
and how those two things translate into
mutation on
frequency detected in our essay so when
we start from patient four you can see
that sativa is the best in terms of
self-dna yields and of course the best
in terms of
minimizing genomic dna contamination
and in this particular instance the
mutation of the frequency detected
and sativa extra is twice as high as
in competitors and but i think
what we need to concentrate is patient
to have a lot of patient
patient to the yield
extracted dissimilar between three kids
and you can see that the amount of
selfie dna is very low in this patient
and again you can see the genomic dna
contamination
is the lowest in in
samples extracted with sativa kit
however or maybe what's important is
that the mutation
i love frequency for extract
extra process with sativa it's almost
seven times higher than what the
competitors get
and this brings us about the brinks
only one conclusion that the reduction
in genomic dna contamination is
specifically important in circumstances
of what
cell to dna is is a limiting factor
okay let's now discuss the results for
patient one and patient three
um and they are both found positive for
mutation and tumor suppressor
protein 53 and this is the protein which
is
quite often mutated in many different in
many different cancers
not so prevalent in non-small cell lung
cancer very prevalent
in a cancer lung cancer associated with
smoking
the protein is composed of three domains
with dna binding domain
and most important photo suppressor
activity
of this protein and also this domain
is um is targeted by a number of
of mutations that are well known
associated with cancer
so this is a mutation hot spot those
mutations
occur and conserve residues that are
listed on this slide
and one of those conserved residues
is mutated in patient one uh please let
me remind you that
patient one uh was only a process would
look at scientific due to the sample
limitation
and i want to concentrate on patient
three because this is slightly
uh slightly more more um
controversial and slightly more
difficult to explain the results
so when we consider um mad max kit
and the extract from magmax kit
we didn't detect any mutation in this
extract
when we have a look at the cytivo kit it
detects the mutation
and that is one of the hot spot mutation
in well-known conserved residue
uh residue however now going to kayaking
kit
we can see that the text mutation and
this mutation is not
a hotspot mutation and
the mutation outlet frequency is 0.35
percent
and this means that the mutation
frequency is unfortunately below the
level of detection
for novel um standard nucleotide
variants and in this
circumstance the clinical scenario this
mutation would be considered
inconclusive result and would have to be
repeated but please write me in mind
that there will be no way of repeating
it because the whole
extract has been already used for
targeted sequencing
and now if we uh dive slightly deeper
deeper
and and mutation on the frequency and we
uh we
will have a look uh at this frequency
uh considering the cell for dna yields
and genomic dna
contamination the sample let's
concentrate
on sample three where we don't see any
concordance between three kids and as
you can see
um kyogen appears to be the best here in
terms of the recovery of selfie dna
while a sativa is quite comparable to
mathematics
the major difference that we see is in
genomic dna contamination again you can
see that
minimal contamination with city bucket
however quite high with mad max and let
me remind you that this is actually the
mad max
kit in which extract no mutation is
being detected
so from those results we can draw one
important conclusion that site
selection-based
extraction allows to detect mutation
associated with cancer in circumstances
where
where those mutations can be can be
missed
when other non-site selection types
of extraction are implemented
okay so just to summarize the whole
presentation
we know that targeted analysis of cell
free dna
is overdue in clinical practice is
widely used for non-invasive prenatal
screening
we also know that is currently
recommended to use
cell free dna for genetic profiling and
advanced cancer and circumstances with
tissue biopsy is not available
a very important aspect of liquid
biopsies and the one that holds
the highest amount of promise is the
fact that it has the potential
and to uncover a full uh genetic
landscape of the evolving tumor so it
can
it can allow for comprehensive uh
decision regarding therapy
at the beginning of the treatment but
also
allows to quickly change the the
therapeutic approach once the resistance
mutation
appear the biggest challenge in the
analysis of selfie dna is the fact that
it constitutes a minor fraction of the
circulation
and the fact that cancer associated
mutations are found at an extremely low
level
um from those experiments that i share
with you
uh it is obvious that size selection
assisted
extraction of sulfur dna allows to
enrich for tumor
derived fraction and this enrichment and
tumor derived fraction allows to detect
mutations
in circumstances when
other kids fail to detect it
okay i think this is it for me and now
it's time for
questions and answers thank you
thank you monica for that wonderful
present movement
we will now move to the q a portion of
this presentation and as a reminder to
our audience members please submit your
questions via the q a box
and monica we already have some great
questions coming in from our audience
members
all right question is is sarah extract a
cell free dna kit compatible
with serum samples
yes it is compatible in fact it's it's
highly recommended for those type
of samples and the reason behind it is
that serum samples are notorious for
genomic dna contamination
and as i presented our kids
is able to remove to some extent this
genome dna contamination
thank you so much now in clinical
applications
what is a preferable sample type is it
serum
or is it plasma um
i believe that there's a general
consensus in the field that plasma is
preferred sample
in clinical applications and this is
based on a number of
reports showing that mutation alert
frequency
and the detection rate of cancer
associated biomarkers is much higher in
plasma samples compared to much
serum samples uh what's probably
important that we shouldn't dismiss
serum samples completely they are very
important
in retrospective studies for biomarker
discovery in large cohorts of
of patients on bio biobank samples
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions
now monica is blood always the best type
of
input sample for cancer detection
well as i said the amount of
and then on the cancer type uh the stage
of cancer the location of the tumor
so there are particular type of cancers
that probably are
not very well suited to be detected in
blood and this will be
bladder and prostate cancer it appears
that urine is more suitable sample
for example for brain cancers it seems
that cerebral spinal fluid
might be more suitable
thank you so much will liquid biopsy
fully replace the tissue biopsy in the
near future
interesting question uh yes it's quite
controversial interesting
um i don't think this is the case i
would i perceive myself
a liquid biopsy as complementary
approach to tissue biopsy
the problem lies in the fact that liquid
biopsy is not universally
applied to all cancers it's not it will
be difficult to replace tissue biopsy
for example
because tumor biopsy provides you the
material to perform histological
assessment of the tumor
and this is the main approach for
subtyping of the cancer
and again in early cancer the
sensitivity of the detection using
a liquid biopsy is quite valuable and
low
and so for those reasons i think this
should be treated as a complementary
approach
thank you so much we have time for a
couple more questions
our next audience member wants to know
what is the plasma
input volume for sarah extracta's cell
free dna kit
and how does it correspond to the volume
of blood needed
okay so so you can get around four mils
of plasma from 10 mils of blood
and the kit has been validated for 0.5
mil
input up to 4 mils
thank you so much we have time for one
more question what is the average amount
of
cfdna per one milliliter of plasma
oh this this varies greatly and and
obviously it depends on the particular
condition that a donor is in
but also it depends on the
pre-analytical and analytical approaches
but if we concentrate on the condition
of the
of the donor this would be in high
picograms to maybe 15 20 nanograms per
ml of plasma and healthy donors and why
in
advance cancer this would probably go
for over
100 nanograms per ml of plasma however i
think there should be a bit of caution
supplies because
applied because for example after
strenuous exercise the amount of
um cellular dna in plasma can go also
above 100 nanograms per ml of plasma
monitor thank you so much for your time
today and for your outstanding
presentation once again
would you like to provide our audience
with any closing remarks before we go
um i i think i said everything that i
want i just want uh
everyone thank everyone for listening
and if you have any particular questions
that
i haven't answered or they were not
something was not clear during the
presentation
please feel free to contact me and write
an email to my email address that
i believe was displayed at the end of
the presentation
thank you so much and i will ditto that
statement thank you to our audience and
please know that any questions
that weren't addressed at this q a will
be addressed
via email by the presenter and this
presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing for 12 months
so please remember to share it with your
colleagues who may be interested in
today's
topic and don't miss out on other
presentations on the agenda
visit the agenda tab in the auditorium
for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
until next time
stay safe and stay healthy take care
everyone bye-bye
thank you everyone bye